bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur arte france d'abord quels sont les
problèmes de ce couvre-feu avancé à 18h
en matière de charge de travail
bonjour déjà effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé il ya en ce moment couple est
horaires et d'organisation quand le
gouvernement décide la veille pour le
lendemain d'échangés
une façon de s'organiser il ya derrière
les personnes il ya des familles à des
enfants et on prend tout le monde de
cours de cette façon là voilà pour pour
l'eau pour les hommes ce qu'il remonte
du terrain c'est sol
les salariés qui se retrouvent avec une
pression d'organisations et de d'aller
au finish
parce que les employeurs leur demande à
chaque fois d'accélérer les cadences de
travail
donc ça veut dire que les employeurs en
fait ne prennent pas en compte les
conditions de travail des salariés dans
sa globalité dans ses basques ou dans la
grande distribution
tous les patrons ne ne considère pas
leurs employés comme la première produit
de richesses pour l'instant ce qui
compte c'est de vendre de la rentabilité
est aujourd'hui si la question du
dimanche parce que ce que reconnaît
aujourd'hui le gouvernement et invite
les préfets de d'élargir et d'ouvrir
avec des décrets les dimanches c'est
parce que le patronat a décidé de mettre
la pression pour qu'on élargisse la
question de du repos dominical dans
notre pays voilà mes jeux
preuve du contraire les patrons de la
grande distribution des grands magasins
leur priorité c'est pas des conditions
du sahara et ça se saurait il n'y a pas
eu d'ouverture de dieu de dialogue
social à ce niveau entre vous les
syndicats et les patronats
vous dire on l'a appris comme tous les
citoyens
là on essaie ça on est face à un
gouvernement qu'ils maîtrisent rien que
dalle
on l'a vu moi je suis pas spécialiste ou
la vue sur le tout ce qui masque on le
voit aujourd'hui sur les vaccins et
c'est pareil
et pour faciliter de bonne conscience il
a trouvé de faciliter dit voilà on va
avoir plus tôt les salariés n'auront pas
de pause entre midi et deux et partiront
plus tôt ou plus tard le soir et entre
temps on oublie que ces salariés
ce ne sont pas des objets ce sont des
humains il ya une vie de famille qui est
derrière
dans le secteur du commerce qu'on
connaît très bien et composé à peu près
de 78 et 80 % de femmes énormément avec
des enfants en bas âge c'est à dire si
vous ouvrez plutôt le matin quand vous
invitez en province sur l'ile-de-france
et ben faut que vous partez une heure ou
deux heures plus tôt c'est à dire vous
laisser les enfants seuls et le soir
c'est la course pour rentrer et sur
l'île de france c'est un désastre parce
qu' énormément de monde sans dans les
transports et on voit encore une fois je
vais le dire alors j'ai mesuré mémo la
compétence de ce gouvernement
quand vous avez des spécialistes et des
chercheurs qui disent qu'il faut éviter
que le brassage de monde et vous avez le
gouvernement qui préconise d'ouvrir le
qui préconise d'ouvrir le dimanche
de fait vous allez avoir autant de monde
et multiplier les risques
le dimanche c'est ça la cité à une
solution mais depuis des années qu'on
propose il faut réduire le temps de
travail
l'histoire des 32 heures permettra à
chacun de finir plus tôt et d'aller
tranquillement faire ses courses parce
que c'est l'argument qu'on lui dit il
faut que les gens puissent consommer et
encore une fois une contradiction avec
ce gouvernement
on dit que les théâtres les cinémas les
remontées mécaniques sont fermés pour
des raisons sanitaires
comment un centre commercial il n'y a
pas de virus devant l'entrée du centre
commercial
c'est l'endroit où il ya plus de monde
il ya aucune garantie sanitaire quand
vous allez dans un centre commercial
dans une galerie marchande
le gouvernement nous a dit pendant des
années vont rouvrir normal la condition
qui a un client sur vu mètre carré moi
je vous prie ordi fille qui le
souhaitent au gouvernement de venir avec
moi dans une galerie marchande ya aucun
contrôle et on ferme à côté et on ferme
à côté
les cinémas vous permet à côté tout ce
qu'il montre de la culture et on pousse
les gens à les faire de la culture
devoir faire du lèche vitrine le
dimanche voilà il ya une incompréhension
totale de cela c'est pour ça que nous on
n'est pas surpris mais effectivement ce
sont encore les salariers je rappelle
quand même que les gens le l'oublient
pas j'étais en première ligne au début
ce qu on appelait ça le travail de
l'ombre
on a payé le prix fort moi j'ai perdu
des collègues de cette maladie on a des
collègues qui sont encore toujours
malades sont les oubliés de cette crise
et on leur demande encore une fois de
sacrifier leur temps et leur vie
justement les revendications de votre
part aujourd'hui et les recours aussi
dont vous disposez pour limiter
justement en appel de ce couvre feu sera
la charge la surcharge de travail que
vous évoquez dont on a entamé avec le
syndicat de clermont ferrand du commerce
une procédure on a bien de causer un
jugement qui qui rétorque l'arrêt
préfectoral encore une fois sur des
données sont des données qui sont
sanitaires voilà le hall un jugement qui
nous est favorable on va essayer de
l'utiliser pour plusieurs départements
pour permettre à ses salariés l'a22 se
reposer une fois par semaine nous ce
qu'on préconise ce compris connaissent
et 32 heures pour tous les salariés de
nos secteurs
vous savez on a un secteur où il ya du
chômage partiel imposé aujourd'hui payés
par nos impôts
je pense à monoprix vous allez on tolère
qu'on ouvre le dimanche mais par contre
on dit pas ces grands groupes à l'été le
chômage partiel et c'est
l'incompréhension
je pense aussi aux autres secteurs qui
sont en difficulté et qui licencient tu
prends le groupe accor qui a annoncé un
plan social
je rappelle que le groupe accor cède que
0,2 sa poche c'est avec notre argent
parce que le chômage partiel est pris à
100% pour cette entreprise et en plus il
ya un accord qui a été signé dix jours
de congés sont prises par l'état et
accor a décidé de licencier ou les fasse
aujourd'hui un système car montré ses
limites car largement se montrer ce qu
ont préconisé en 2h30 de reconnaissance
des métiers nos secteurs
je rappelle ce sont des engagements de
l'ancien ministre du travail qui avaient
avancé pendant la crise ou à la
découverte
ces salariés de l'ombre été utile à la
société je rappelle qu'on attend
énormément de sahraj je pense aux agents
de sécurité ont payé le prix fort 17
agents de sécurité qui sont décédées
pendant cette période dans le commerce
on a recensé 3 4 femmes qui sont
décédées suite aux copines
voilà où nous aurons dit que c'est
reconnaître ces métiers là d'augmenter
de salaire et surtout surtout le plus
vite possible d'empêcher l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche pour permettre à
ces hommes et des femmes qui font la
richesse de ce pays de se reposer parce
que depuis le mois de mars assure
largement donné tord temps merci
beaucoup à vous amara à la ga je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la fédération cgt commerce et
services